welcome to and thanks for coming to my
talk we're going to talk about
developing dashboard applications using
a bouquet so this is an example I like
to highlight I think this is like a good
distillation of what like we the bouquet
people are trying to do our kind of like
mission statement is that we're trying
to connect PI data tools and users to
interactive web visualization this is
the tool developed by the the Kepler
folks at NASA Kepler is a satellite that
uh picks up like a electromagnetic
radiation from outer space to try to
detect was out there and they've built a
tool that they use to like examine like
the the flux signal again on individual
pixels so to look the signal so they can
do kind of like manual data cleaning and
so they you know the people like writing
like building these tools are like like
hardcore astronomy like PhD people and
so we really want to like help them be
able to develop like really effective
powerful visualizations without them
having to like worry too much about like
web technology and stuff I think like
when people like before they get to this
you know like they'll come to us and say
like yeah you know I like I made an
image and I put it on a page and then I
want to change it and so I like figured
out how to make an HTML button and now I
was googling Ajax and you're like no
that's like like that's terrible like
like astronomers should not be gluing
Ajax right like they they so we have a
tool like this to try to like help them
get past that barrier and we sort of
like see this story like over and over
and so like from the the top left we
like see people in the domains of
engineering finance there's some like
vial of you RNA people there's some
social science stuff where these are all
domain experts and you really want to
like help them create visualizations
without being bogged down and like the
the web tech part of it we're really
excited this month we finally had our
1.0 announcement
didn't take us the SyFy 20 years but it
took us like five and so bouquet like
like was it now it's it's a pretty big
library and so includes like both all
like the applying primitives that like
you need to make sort of any kind of
visualization you want like the the
circles and the lines is like you really
build up from the base blocks to make
visualizations book alphas interactive
plot tools so you can be like the
dragging and the highlighting of
elements even your plots we have a set
of HTML widgets like sliders and
dropdowns that you use to kind of build
up interactive visualizations we have
some native support for specialized such
a visualizations like network like graph
and like geo daya like either plan on
top of Google Maps or if you have geo
JSON we're able to ingest that and make
maps that way we target a variety
back-end so apart from just browsers we
do various notebooks like super
notebooks you've lab Zeppelin like the
the spark notebook we have a JavaScript
callbacks on day and event changes so
you can write snippets of JavaScript
that can do things either inside your
plot or outside like in the the larger
page or using our like bouquets server
which is a Python process you're able to
make server-side callbacks and it make
changes back and forth and then there's
more book in that so this talks
specifically we're going to touch on on
four major things the first three are
general to all kind of bouquet
visualizations that you can make both
like static and and server ones first
we'll talk about building up
visualizations from like the the
building blocks we're going to talk
about making digital ins styling using
palettes and themes we'll talk about
some layouts both like what you can do
internally in bouquet and like how you
can use kind of modern web layout
engines and then a like what like using
like a bouquet server application dozen
we have a demo for this too and so this
will be in the demo and it will actually
be in color because I might have a
faster laptop and I did when I wrote
this example but we'll do a face
detection so we'll do streaming a face
detection using an open CV
which is I think like a good example of
wealth like not like a really a PI data
ecosystem tool because it's like a seed
library with wrappers on it you know
like we're going to be doing some like
you know machine learning to recognize
faces when pushing updates to the
browser so this is like the the my most
important slide if you take nothing away
from this talk except this like like
learn this and so bouquet like like what
you really need to do is you need to
pick the graphical primitives you want
you so like pick like the lines and the
circles that like you used to build up
your visualization provide the data and
then specify how the data maps to these
primitives that you use and so like like
let the day of specify like the size of
things or the color of things and and
boco take care of the rest and this is
like a mocha really wants to be a
declarative library where there's like a
we've abstracted a lot of like the the
logic of like like how circles get
placed somewhere and you just kind of
define how it works you know lay it out
ok primitives we call glyphs and they
really are these like simple Python
objects with a bunch of attributes on
them that you set and so on the bottom
is an example of our our circle glyph
and we said some things and when we
serialize it to JSON really is just a
simple JSON object and so bouquet
visualizations are you build up
collections of these Python objects that
we see realize all JSON and feed to a
client library called bouquet jjs that
knows how to consume and rebuild all of
these objects in JavaScript and then
knows how to output them all as canvas
or SVG this is a pretty common patterns
is just for visualization libraries plot
lead is a very similar like collection
Python objects if they see row as a JSON
over
altaïr builds up objects that they
serialize to a spec for a JavaScript
library called Vega and this is like a
really good way to like target friend
libraries because then like when people
want to create new language bindings
like we have our bouquet language
binding they really don't have to build
this
like our models that hit this json spec
and they're able to like take advantage
of all the nice stuff a bouquet will not
do a ton of work sometimes writing
dative and visualizations we have this
object called a column datasource and
really the the important takeaway is
it's it's named columns and so you can
build them from dictionaries you can
build them directly from pans data
frames which is also a named column type
object and when you put these together
you really are making the the properties
of these glyphs aligned with named
columns in this column datasource and so
these are two different paths that bokeh
has but really all you're saying is like
on this plot I want some circles where
the the X values correspond to some
column in the source name time the Y
corresponds to some value
yo named sorry to a column name value in
the source and same with color and you
can do with any of these glyph
properties and so to rewrite you know we
pick the primitives we want it was like
we want to do circles we we provide the
day and these columns and then we do the
mapping and bouquet takes care of the
rest and so this really is like a valid
bouquet incantation like like to be like
I want to create like a scatter plot
really is just like I want the circles I
want these columns to line up and and I
have some data palettes and themes so
booking ships with a lot of nice color
palettes we apart from want people to
create visualizations like it's it's
really important that they're visually
pleasing to be more powerful picking
colors is hard I'm not good at picking
colors and so we ship with like a some
Brewer color palettes and d3 color
palettes so you're not faced with like
what colors I use you're like blue and
so that's like another like you know
nice nice tea that we're hoping to
abstract from people the specific
visualization is made with a tool called
hollow views
which is a good time to mention that
like a book it's also a good target to
build on top of and a lot of people do
because like on the Python side all
bouquets is really these collections of
simple Python objects and so it's
relatively straightforward for other
tools to be able to just build these
these collections and then take
advantage of like the rest of the
downstream tooling a bouquet bouquet
also use includes the perceptually
uniform color palettes that were
developed by matt plot Tom Caswell and
some other the Matt plot people gave a
really good-size talk like three years
ago if you're ever interested I used to
do light stuff and this it's a variant
you talk about like how you develop
colors that like look like twice more
intense and actually correctly reflect
like the data values being like twice as
large and both can have some nice
utilities of allowing you to map color
palettes on today of ranges and so you
can say like oh I have this column
there's probably values between you know
zero and a hundred on there
I just want bouquet to like you know
apply this like this one's called fire
there's like fire palette on to there
and so the high value is the most
intense and the lowest is the the least
intense and just take care of it we also
have a feature we call themes where as
we discussed previously bouquet objects
are a bunch of attributes and so you can
write these um either JSON or yeah mole
files that you include that essentially
overwrite all the default values of your
bouquet primitives it's great for
several reasons first it's like if you
have multiple plots it's a really good
way to maintain consistent plots it's
you you get in a bad spot when you're
like oh I've decided I want to change
the background color of all my plots so
you have to go six different places in
your code and change a single value this
is the way I make a change once this
also forces you to use good development
practices in like web development you
know there's the
suggestion that you you know you
maintain your business logic and your
JavaScript files in your your styling
logic and your CSS files so when you
want to make changes you know where to
look and this is a similar thing where
you know if you have a visualization
you're like oh like I want to change
like the padding or the color or
something you know where to look first
is your your business logic and so our
community is actually like started to
create and share their own styles and so
I have all Boca attributes are able to
be changed and so people change like the
font and the padding and the the
background colors and specifically
exciting that you can then like now I
develop your own but you can just pick
other people's one drop in your
visualization like essentially reskin
the whole thing let's talk about layouts
bouquet plots can be responsive and so
they don't have to be you can set fixed
sizes but if you want them to kind of
naturally like expand to fit a webpage
that's a thing we can do we also have
various like responsive modes where if
it's really important that maintains the
aspect ratio you can side to do that or
you can have it like expand like in
whatever dimension makes sense and then
build on top of that there's a we have a
pure Python API to lay out sets of plots
and kind of a row and column style way
and so in this one like a we're trying
to lay out like a large plot and then
two and then three and it looks
something like this and you know this is
a great looking visualization it fits a
is very nicely responsive so if you drag
around it will resize appropriately we
also do some like nice subtle visual
things where I'm not going to rip my
thing out but um your notes on the left
side the the vertical axes are aligned
even though there's not like a title on
the bottom left it really could like
come like expand to the left a little
bit more it actually looks nice
we maintain the the parity between the
the axes we can also do things where
it's not in this example where you can
share tools so right now the bottom
three all like have the same tool set
which isn't a great look and we can do
things like where they they all are
collected into one single bin and you
can use the same tools across several
plots bouquet we also allow and in vein
plots in your own ginger templates this
isn't a CSS grid talk but let me talk
about CSS for a second there's a new CSS
layout engine called CSS grid which is
amazing for dashboards it's like the the
graves to a whole time
it lets you define like split a
container into kind of arbitrary spaces
and then when you put things inside it
you say I want to start at this like
arbitrary line and end at this arbitrary
line both vertically and horizontally
desc distributed has a diagnostic UI
that they use and and they use this very
well so they have this a desk is like a
distributed computing framework and so
there's some diagnostic pages to know
whether or not work is being
appropriately distributed among
different client workers and so they
have this task stream plot where each
horizontal grouping is like a different
node and like in this case I'll just do
it evenly but like they're able to like
diagnosed in cases where like what one
workers hogging a bunch of tasks but
they have a very specific demands of
what they want where they wanted this
task 1 to be really large and so they
divide their page in like two in thirds
vertically and in like fifth this way
and so they want to be 2/3 and 3/5 and
then have the other things kind of fit
around it and there's a drag smaller
it's nice responsive so that you
use all of their screen space but when
they hit half like a half screen they
use a CSS feature called media queries
which apply like different sets of CSS
rules basing on a screen size and so
when they hit this breakpoint it totally
changes and they apply a whole different
like CSS grid rule which move the plots
around and so again that they are like
making maximal use of their the visual
space I guess a common workflow for deaf
folks is to have a book like half stupid
notebook where they're like doing
interactive computation then like
viewing the other one so this is like a
like fantastic use of like writing their
own jinda templates and Brian CSS to
make it work
so let's poke a server so we talked
previously about this like middle part
where Python objects i've serialize to
json into like kind of mirroring
javascript objects the output voce
server adds a layer where there's a
WebSocket that keeps these objects in
sync and so if you make changes to the
JavaScript object like if for some
reason like you're like I'm dragging a
slider or I'm highlighting things it
will send updates to the Python process
and so you can then attach callbacks and
do things and then the reverse is true
too you can make Python changes based on
some sort of callback at some RPC and
your data come in and so you can update
your objects you know push changes the
front-end and they'll be reflected in
what you see in the browser and then of
course we like maintain like a separate
user session so like you can have one
running server and like a bunch of
difficult use it you won't like drag out
with people's sliders so this is like an
example this select thing is like a
drop-down and so based on like someone
picking different values out of the
drop-down we're changing the title of a
plot we have some nice utility functions
on these data source objects
where we can do smarter updates so we're
able to stream data and so in the case
of like we're doing a time series we're
getting new day and every time we don't
want to send all the historical data to
the front end to like advocate single
elements we're able like to add just a
new one we're able to patching which is
like more common for kind of like image
stuff like people will do like tile
based map stuff and like they'll zoom
and then they want to relay out there
just like a specific part of the tile
and so they use this and then probably
the most important part is these a
collection of these Python objects we
call a document and so you're able to
make document level callbacks this an
example of just a periodic callback and
so this is actually for the final
example like we will get like a new
image every so many milliseconds you're
always able do push one so if you have
some sort of RPC or you're reading off a
queue and waiting for new events to come
in you're able to arbitrarily push new
messages to the front end so it is
example time oh you're right that helps
what's that plugged into oh it's my
personal webcam one sec we will go the
nicer one though
okay so action I turn around there we go
the Lighting's a little difficult but
and so like why this example like apart
from like you know being clever whatever
I think it's like a good distillation of
what we're trying to do with bouquet in
terms of we are able to like do kind of
like relatively computationally
intensive Python stuff and then make
make visualization so in this case we're
actually detecting faces using open CV
and then Korean like a visually nice
dashboard this one I think is nicely
responsive using bootstrap I'm in full
screen so I can a drag it I'll set that
down for now oh no
so that like that that example is a
created by a user who you know I was
interested in doing like a face
detection thing and wanted like a
visually nice dashboard and was able to
kind of put together without really
using web technologies I think it has
some like copy and paste bootstrap which
is a thing that most people able to do
it's that's largely to learn more we
have our github page documentation we
have a really active mailing list so if
you have user questions please submit to
our mailing list we have a pretty active
Gator chat which are more questions of
like like I'm interested in doing
something this how would I even start
and then we have a pretty large corpus
of Boquete content on Stack Overflow if
you have specific questions thank you so
much yeah so the question was about
bouquets 3d support bouquet has a
feature that we call custom extensions
so users are able to kind of write their
own primitives that then get like a
wrapped up with the rest of bokeh stuff
and deployed there is in our like
example repo there is an example of a 3d
like a street map plot or whatever where
someone had written a their own custom
extension where it's pretty large and
very specific and so I don't think we'll
merge it into the core library but if
you're interested like you would just
essentially adopt this cosmic stanchion
and use it yourself and so we have this
feature for a lot of stuff that seems
like good but not useful enough to the
the larger community like we um our
JavaScript library is already pretty
large and so we're trying to not to like
keep like page load size down we're
trying to
Mergent features that like really only
target like one user just cuz like we're
already at like seven are like kilobytes
or something I really don't want like
hit a Meg
a visitor will see about multiple inputs
and this is specific breath their way
like yes
we do allow accessing query parameters a
URL and so you are able to like if you
have a bunch of sliders there are
different points you could like read
them from you could you could create the
URL and then send it to someone and then
when the the thing is generated on the
Python side it could read the query
parameters set the slider to the right
point when the page loads yeah I don't
think there's a great way for you to
like drag a plot and save like the state
of that plot you like I have to manually
do the query parameter stuff but as a
thing that users do analysis energy per
notebook or something like that doing
data aggregations in panda matplotlib or
Seabourn to visualize stuff and then
kind of always wanting a little bit more
from that or like wanting to somehow
HTML eyes that page to send to somebody
so they do know you know we don't have
to push up to github where would ok fit
in that in terms of just is it a
replacement for those other libraries I
could just like inline those
visualizations and then maybe in a
jeepers notebook or then output them to
HTML and then somebody can work with my
tables or my visualizations more
interactively yes make sense yeah so the
question is about kind of building like
like like static HTML visualizations you
can do things and so people have built
kind of cross filter applications first
you essentially have to have all of your
data in the web browser and so if it's a
static paging of a Python process you
also like convert your whole pants Dave
into I have a good example this actually
yeah here we actually have a good
example that I will show you so we have
this one is currently a server one but
you could do the the same day of slicing
in JavaScript instead but essentially
like there's a large in-memory table
that's a bunch of movies or whatever and
you're able to kind of slice and dice it
does filtering and essentially like the
the state of all of these widgets are
kind of like accessible and so each time
you make a change it does essentially
like a big like a bunch of like filters
on this big like in-memory table and and
regenerates the output and so this is a
pretty common thing that people do as
well
I think in that case that's it thank you
so much for coming everyone
[Applause]